I can see you're seeing an advanced
screening of Arthur I don't let people
have been asking me lately know how I
get into all these screenings and
honestly I know people I'm friends with
people in various industries and I get
emails about different promotions and I
get to see a lot of the movies early
it's very nice Arthur is a remake and it
stars Russell Brand and basically a very
similar character to what he was playing
in get him to the Greek he's an
incredibly rich man he squanders his
wealth on pointless things like dressing
up as Batman and parading around town
the Batmobile
there's women all over the place and
he's drunk all the time it's an
alcoholic and he's basically the same
character but he's good at playing that
character his nannies played by Helen
Mirren and she basically cleans up after
him all the time and his mother's
getting very tired of all of his various
wanderings and forces him to marry
Jennifer Garner or she'll cut off his
wealth but the problem is he met a girl
that he actually starts to love and so
the comedy ensues Russell Brand's very
good in this film I liked him a lot he
was very likable and Helen Mirren also
was very good they had excellent
chemistry together both of them and it
was the strongest point of the film by
far which actually brings me to the
worst part of the film since that
relationship was so well portrayed and
so strong and both of the actors did
such a nice job for trying their
characters one of the main things were
supposed to care about in this movie is
his relationship with this girl that he
meant that he actually loves didn't
believe that relationship whatsoever
didn't believe the chemistry didn't
think there was any romance just wasn't
into that at all so basically that
entire portion of the film that
strengths that were supposed to feel and
wanting him to be with the other girl
wasn't there also the woman who betrays
that girl she's from greenberg I forget
her name I thought she did a really bad
job it seemed like all of her comedy
came clearly from a script didn't seem
like she
improvisational skills that all it just
seemed all very force on the other hand
Russell Brand had a lot of wit a lot of
charm a lot of really good lines came
from him not very much of the comedy has
laugh out loud you know it's not just
like oh my gosh that's so funny is with
a lot of witty charm basically Helen
Mirren is actually pretty funny in this
movie too like a lot of comedies like
this the film starts to try to get
serious towards the end and in some ways
it works but in some ways it just
doesn't and that's always a tough line
to walk in comedies like this the whole
story of the film is so forced it seems
like you know hey let's get this kind of
funny idea we get this character who's
like this who's just a slob and we'll
throw him in there and have him all of a
sudden have to make adult decisions and
it'll be funny and it seems like they
didn't really care too much about the
actual plot of the film they just were
relying on Russell Brand's comedic
talents which he does have it doesn't
feel like a movie it feels just like an
excuse to have various comedic scenes
supporting technology who is a great
actor who for some reason just doesn't
seem like he can even speak anymore he's
wasted in this movie and his character
is just odd and very weird and it seems
like they just used him to try to get
some pointless comedy at times it just
did not work I can see the director
being like okay Nick Nolte we're gonna
do this scene and we're gonna add these
little little funny parts in it that you
have to do and he's like I don't think
so that's not working out for me cause
you know I'm Nick Nolte and I apparently
can't speak anymore and I'm starting to
get fat I'm a very talented actor and
I'm just nothing to do it here's a
million dollars yeah okay let's do it
Russell Brand has wit and he has charm
Helen Mirren does also but the story of
the film and it's just it's not really
that funny like you're not going to be
rolling more than likely so I'm gonna
give this movie 2 out of 4 stars
it's an OK film it's just there's
something missing